and the answer goes to
Tilda Swinton
this is the first Academy Award in
nomination for Tilda Swinton
oh no
uh
happy birthday man
I have an American
agent who is the spitting image of this
really truly the same shape head and it
has to be said the buttocks
and I'm giving this to him because
there's no way I would be in America at
all ever on a plane if it wasn't for him
so Brian swartstrom I'm giving this to
you
and
Tony Gilroy walks on water it's entirely
official as far as I'm concerned and Jen
Fox and Steve Samuels are incredible
producers and Sydney
and George Clooney you know the
seriousness and the dedication to your
art seeing you climb into that rubber
bat suit from Batman and Robin the one
with the nipples every morning under
your costume on the set off the set
hanging upside down at lunch you rock
man thank you thank you thank you
foreign